alright guys I'm super excited I got Ari
Paul here we've got a lot to talk about
so thank you for coming thank you for
having me Anthony absolutely alright
let's just run through your background
real quick and kind of what you guys are
doing a block tower and then we can get
into the good stuff
sure yeah really quick was a Poli Sci
major in college played a lot of Poker
both of those those things are actually
kind of applicable here then was a
market maker and active trader force us
planter national group and a couple prop
desks then was a long-term investor for
university chicago endowment it's a
portfolio manager risk manager and then
launch block tower which is a crypto
investment firm that does kind of
anything and everything in crypto that
we we think we have engine got it the
endowment world is very risk-averse to
some degree they think much much longer
term than most investors they've got
permanent capital to net10 extent what
got you excited about crypto and then
eventually forced you into jumping in a
whole bunch of things so from the
endowment perspective our job as
endowment investors is to find to find
alpha and and to do many other things
like manage risk but investing has
become hard it's a very competitive
space but we and you know it whether
it's you Chicago where I was or or Yale
or Harvard
you've access to the best fund managers
in the world who are brilliant
incredibly hard-working and yet they
really struggled outperform the market
so the best managers in the world and
public equities for example might add
two or three percent half a year and and
that you know I don't know if that's a
lot or a little but if you're thinking
about some of the smartest people in the
world and you're think about a market
where it seems like it should be more
opportunity so something we try to think
about is where does alpha come from and
where should we look for it in an active
sense so US equities are easy to invest
in there's very little barriers to entry
it's very easy to understand gap
accounting so it's very competitive so
there's very little alpha basically the
alpha gets competed away frontier
markets emerging markets there's less
liquidity there's regulatory risk
there's less transparency there's more
complexity you literally need to spend
more time you need to do physical travel
even
things like physical travel actually are
a source of alpha because there's a lot
of managers who don't leave their
families and Greenwich and spend six
months sitting in you know South Africa
Zimbabwe or Venezuela or wherever and so
I tried to take the mentality of
thinking actively like where where is
there not competition and crypto kind of
jumped out at me as there's all these
reasons why it's incredibly hard to
trade invest and crypto right custody
regulatory clarity complexity of you
knows almost no one in the world who
actually understands all the relevant
pieces no economic models there's a lack
of data all of these are very real
obstacles and therefore make it
potentially a really attractive place to
find alpha so it you know it before 2017
this was like a five billion dollar
asset class or at least start of 2016 is
about a five billion dollar asset class
wasn't investable so we were an eight
billion dollar endowment
by late 2016 I thought okay I think this
is getting ready for primetime I'm
seeing the start of institutionalization
I think this is gonna power Baalak I
think in a year this is gonna be
investable by endowments let me start
laying the groundwork let me socialize
the idea let me educate my colleagues so
we can get in hopefully before kind of
other it's not even other endowments I
actually wanted all endowments to
capture some of the wealth creation I
didn't want it all to go to Silicon
Valley types and meeseeks I wanted
nonprofits to capture some of it so I
produce some educational materials that
you've Chicago and share them with some
other endowments because it's not really
competition right and I'm pretty happy
if Harvard and Yale also benefit and
that was kind of the angle of finding
alpha and then for me personally it's a
kind of a traitor's playground so
traditional markets trading is pretty
difficult again just competition and
then encrypt oh it's hard so you have
counterparty risk to exchanges you had
you know there are a lot of very
reasonable reasons why good trader
wouldn't want to have a ton of money
sitting on exchange like mount cox and
so that provides opportunity algorithmic
trading is incredibly hard because
Exchange API connections are terrible
that's another barrier you know it's all
those barriers make it very attractive
if you're willing to put in that time
and effort to overcome them and then the
last which was what originally got me
into crypto in 2014 was the the kind of
original cyberpunk vision of this is a
tool to fight oppression this is a tool
for the the 1% of the world who or I
think it's a tool for everyone in many
ways but but first
for most primarily primarily the most
important element to me at least was
this is a tool for the 1% who for some
reason can't use other forms of money so
the state refuses the given bank account
or it's a refugee fleeing Syria or Iran
with the shirts on their backs again the
state won't literally physically will
not let them leave with it with with via
yeah we're gold it it's funny I don't
know this stat but Bitcoin or other
cryptocurrencies has already surpassed
some currencies in the world right so
it's not the bottom it may be the sixth
to the bottom seventh to the bottom
whatever but over time if it continues
to move up the charts right that's
progress to some degree and what you're
talking about is it's not attacking the
developed world's currency it's not
going after the US dollar you know the
Euro etc so after the weakest right it's
kind of killing those off or surpassing
them at places like Venezuela etc and I
think we we've got to see more of those
weak currencies die off over time but
really why why is that happening is
because people are opting in right it's
this idea that it is better it's better
serves them to some degree whatever
they're trying to accomplish it
definitely said that's a little bit of a
kind of a connected but different use
case so so I'm talking about kind of the
ability to flee with your money I think
the way Bitcoin potentially kills off
currencies and we've seen this in is in
Bob wait Venezuela and not killing off
the currency but being much more widely
adopted there than elsewhere
percentage-wise
and that's the depreciation was this is
an use case which if if you're if you're
US dollars are being inflated away three
percent per year there isn't much
pressure if it's a hundred percent a
year or five hundred percent a year
that's if that's a real good incentive
to look for alternatives so definitely
the weakest currencies are the ones
where there's the most pressure for
people to to learn how to have a Bitcoin
absolutely let's talk a little bit more
about endowments right so everyone keeps
talking about the institutions are
coming the institutions are coming we've
obviously talked to a bunch of them
we've got some that you know are in our
funds but why are more of them not in
right so we've seen at this point I
think we've seen Harvard Yale MIT Notre
Dame stamp for UNC you know so a good
number of the kind of forward-thinking
best known best performing ones but why
hasn't everyone else jumped in so hard
so I think there's one more step to how
this always unfolds which is you need
the success
a point that then it the phrase I like
of it applies in so many circumstances
with anything kind of market psychology
or investor psychology is fear versus
FOMO what is the driving force for the
investor at that time is it fear of loss
fear of career risk fear of looking
stupid or is it fear of missing out so
now that the first wave of bets have
been made if you get one quarter or one
year where Yale's tiny allocation I
don't know what they allocate as percent
of their their entire portfolio but it's
it's probably trivial it's probably less
than 0.25 percent if that little piece
in a quarter let's say is up to hundred
percent that may return more than the
other 99.5% of their portfolio that will
result in a news story then suddenly
every other cio and investment office
around the country is being asked by the
president University why they passed on
that investment why did why did you pass
on the best investment Yale's made in
the last decade so suddenly it shifts
the burden from why are you investing in
tulips why are you crazy this massive
risk to the risk of not but that doesn't
happen until you get the successful data
point can't you say that already right
so one of the couple of sets that we
like to talk to these institutions about
is look it's the best performing asset
class in the last ten years it's the
best performing asset in last five years
it's still up 400% in the last two years
right it did have a big drawdown in 2018
or according this end of November of
2018 but the performance has still
outperformed everything else in your
portfolio with those draw downs why is
that not good enough success data point
is it because the institutions weren't
actually and they can't say we evaluate
the situation we made the decision and
here's our specific returns versus like
back testing or what yeah that was a
thought process there yeah so I it's I'm
not I don't like this because I think it
leads to poor results on behalf of
endowments and this is true basically
all most investment decision making is
bureaucratic to some degree you rarely
have just an individual controlling
billions of dollars of capital and the
decision-making it plays out like this
it's you're not looking in the abstract
you are complete you are competing
psychologically against specific players
so in the endowment world Harvard and
Yale and you Chicago and you Penn they
don't care how a sovereign wealth fund
in Dubai did they don't care how a
pension fund in Japan did they care how
ten other endowments in the u.s. did
because
that's what they're benchmarked against
that's what the that's what their alumni
compared them to and so if no one in if
those top ten endowments weren't in
crypto last year the results never
happened didn't matter
there's no psychological pressure to
follow the herd because the herd is
those ten endowments for those ten now
for a sovereign wealth fund in Singapore
I don't know what their benchmark is
maybe it's the Dubai maybe it's the
Emirates sovereign wealth funds in other
words like there's different herds the
endowment herd is kind of its own little
herd of like 10 to 20 top endowments
that and they really view themselves as
isolated from everything else got it
let's talk about the market for a second
right you've got this unique view that
no one's really talking about of there's
been a complete retrace retracement of
the market back to like September of
2017 levels talk about that a little bit
yeah so I um I did not I I don't claim
to have called this bear market you know
explicitly or well so this is not a like
patting myself on the back as a call
this is just kind of more of an
explained to explanatory framework I
guess there's at this temptation by a
lot of people to say in fact it was an
article but this is the headline Jamie
Dimon and Rivini proved right cryptos
dead because it's now 75 or 80 percent
so that like there's this framework of
like how could an asset be down 75 80
percent if it wasn't fundamentally
broken and and that's just like silly so
Bitcoin was at 3,000 last September it
was at 3,000 last September and from a
technical analysis perspective that was
the start of the retail parabolic bull
rally that was a speculative short-term
bubble and we've just retraced that we
basically retraced a two-month
speculative parabolic move in other
words you don't need a fundamental
change to do that you just had people
who got over Leverett overzealous they
were momentum chasers and you retrace
that move the unusual thing is in stocks
when the same thing happens it just
happens just such a smaller degree so
you I mean we saw the cannabis stocks
and that was kind of extreme that was a
rare case but the key thing I was try to
remember is crypto assets are the price
movements are logarithmic meaning
meaning you get these 10x advances you
get these 80% collapses it's just a
hyper volatile asset that's not unique
to crypto you see the same thing in Pink
Sheets in any kind of hyper volatile
speculative ass
we're fundamental value is unclear and
especially where there's kind of these
intrinsic vicious and virtuous cycles so
that this gets into kind of a whole
interesting area of something that is
fundamental different about crypto from
say equities is you don't have a
liquidation value and in fact it's it's
the opposite it's kind of bad so as
Bitcoin falls lower in price it is less
valuable so it has less liquidity it's
less useful as a medium of change it's
less useful as a store of value it's
security worsens so hash power is tied
to price at the best case scenarios that
has power falls gradually with price
that means it's a less secure network
and less valuable the worst-case
scenario is that you faced along gating
block times you face greater risk of 51%
attack you face potentially a air-quote
half power death spiral which by the way
I think is an exaggerated risk that is
very unlikely to cause the death of
Bitcoin but it could absolutely cause
40-minute block times and rising
transaction fees which fundamentally is
a less valuable network so there's this
natural momentum to crypto assets that
actually they are more valuable when
they're worth more and they're less
viable are worth less which which
accentuates the sigh praval attila t so
that the big picture is you need to be
the equivalent like if Microsoft goes up
two percent of the day and then down two
percent the next day we're not all
scrambling to figure out why the hell
did that happen we get that there's some
noise there's some volatility in crypto
that 2% is more like 20 and a normal
market cycle is like an 80% down or a
you know 500 percent up do you think
that that volatility goes away at some
point like is it just market maturity
more liquidity kind of more
institutional investors maybe some
algorithmic trading that goes on that
kind of smoothes that volatility or you
think it's it's a more I I've even
actually seen people who say look it's
gonna get more violent I think for the
foreseeable future meaning the next
decade
I don't expect a radical change so it's
gonna stay hyperbolic now so Bitcoin
volatility has been trending down for
for the last 10 years so as follows has
been in the last year it's less volatile
than wasn't 2010 or 2014 so it may
become you know that we may get that
same thing in five years we may say okay
it's a little bit less volatile but it's
still instead of a 10x and then 80
percent down maybe it's a 6x and then a
70% down or um I think in the reasons
for that or what I just kind of talked
about there is this fundamental
intrinsic momentum to Bitcoin
and then most other crypto assets are
like seed stage VC investments which are
naturally hyper volatile their
experiments their early safe startups as
long as you're so if we're talking out a
crypto asset that is basically a startup
it's gonna be volatile like a startup
we're talking about a crypto asset that
he has these ingrained kind of momentum
driven Network effects it's still
probably gonna be volatile I also think
we're so far from maturity in air quotes
so far right I mean we have 30 million
people in the world maybe who own
Bitcoin we have a lot of regulatory
challenges and I mean that in the
abstract sense so a phrase from famous
neva lava conte was that the this isn't
we haven't seen the final boss yet the
final boss being some state level attack
in a way that's far more serious than
like China banning you know mining kind
of thing so there's a lot of that stuff
ahead of us that are we're gonna more
hard Forks we're gonna more hash power
Wars in many ways the scale of the
battle is just increasing you're gonna
see far more shrewd actors far more
tenacious sharks entering this this game
I was having a conversation last night
we were talking about with some
developers and we're talking about how
rare engineering based attacks on crypto
networks are so there's so many buggy
crypto networks and there's so many
known vulnerabilities why aren't those
bugs exploited more often why aren't
people constantly like you know there
was the verge mining attack where people
gamed The Verge algorithm and created
artificial inflation there'd been zero
day attacks but why aren't there many
more of those I actually think a big
part of its psychological the hackers in
the space the engineers the devs who
know how to do that they're not some of
them are ethical and some of them are
just uninterested in killing a network
but they're also just not that kind of
mindset of sharks who are looking to
make every penny and doing whatever they
need to and now the Wall Street's
getting in the game now that that you
know the financially minded people now
the ability to short now the things like
I mean so you can short Bitcoin with
futures but most assets you can't really
short but it's things like dy/dx come
out if I can put on a meaning flick
let's use version as an example if I
could snap my fingers and destroy the
verge network there's almost no way for
me to profit from that
I can't just short verge so I have no
incentive to do it if I could short 20
million dollars of urghhh then maybe I
do a zero-day attack so I'm not saying I
would but someone probably but that's
logic right right you know who who
actually reminds me of this a little bit
is Arthur Hayes right so Arthur you know
I joke all tommix that dude thinks
differently right and in like a super
positive way I say that right of just
when you hear him talk he has a more
aggressive kind of bent to the way he
thinks and some of its I think some of
the you know the wall street type
mentality etc into your point as more of
those people come in I think that it
changes the dynamic of the market
because the participants are willing to
look at risk differently they're willing
to become more aggressive that you know
there's all these different components
to it and you know I wonder if that
actually washes out some of the people
who aren't willing aren't expecting to
have to do that who have been you know
the traders and the market participants
before that happens I don't know I don't
know if I wash them out but I think it's
funny like battles in crypto so far have
mostly been kind of Internet trolling
like I said something mean to me on
Twitter little billionaire mode yeah
yeah good luck and now what we see with
Bitcoin cash for example is like Calvin
I are the Bodog billionaire and and this
is kind of the first III the SVA BC
battle has been fascinating and it's it
still feels a little amateurish to me so
this is not like quite wall street level
yet in terms of playing chicken and
price wars and you look at what what
some of the I mean you would like United
Fruit Company basically assassinating
dictators in South America in the 1960s
with help of the Dulles brothers to
increase profit margins that's where
crypto is headed like that's just that's
just humanity that's just the nature of
the world if you have enough money at
stake and in crypto there's a natural
it's funny it's a lot of public
blockchains a lot of transparency it's
also inherently less transparent so the
fact that you can potentially if you're
world-class hacker destroyed 20 billion
dollars of value from a remote computer
in Estonia and maybe get away with it is
is incredible whereas United Fruit
Company had actually like sent
helicopters to South America so it's
it's incredibly tempting and in some
ways easy and and now you're getting the
financial incentive to do it you're
attracting that kind of person like
we've seen with Calvin I our partner and
Craig people who are who are looking for
opportunities to get their hands dirty
in that way so the what are the
conclusions of that so one is if you're
a traitor
the nice thing about trading and
investing is you can only be taken
advantage of if your trade right so so
you can't get whipsawed and you can't
get chopped up by market makers or by
bike shenanigans basically if you buy an
asset you fundamentally believe in and
don't touch it will necessarily be the
best result and I'm not saying people
should be passive but you don't have to
play those games you don't have to guess
it what's gonna happen with sv and ABC
you don't have to try to tell you to
fish at the table you can just kind of
not be at the table and then we're think
about an ETF I have no insight here I
would put it 5050 that it happens in the
next I was gonna say six months call it
nine months
59 so let's say that whether you know at
some point it's gonna happen that could
be six nine could be three years right
who knows but what do you think the
impact is when it happens is it kind of
what the consensus at this point around
ETF gets approved price appreciates or
do you think that there's an another you
know potential outcome there so
definitely on the announcement Bitcoin
would skyrocket III mean I would
personally be bidding it up at least 50%
like I think it I don't know except does
go up 100% or 200% or 30% I'm not sure
and then the questions what happened
with the futures was we this massive
parabolic rally into the release of the
see me and CB futures at the end of last
year and then all of those people had
like they were anticipating the futures
and then sold into it the high was
almost exactly with the launch so we
might get that again with an ETF so for
example if Bitcoin rallied from you know
wherever four thousand to twelve
thousand on the announcement and then
six months later the ETF came out in
Bitcoin was at thirty thousand that
might be a great time to sell it might
be a great time to try to end it you
know because basically the market will
have been pricing in a year or two years
of inflows into the ETF yep but but long
term I think it's huge because it's
massive it basically settles the
question in everyone's mind forever of
regulatory status of Bitcoin which
sounds stupid cuz you and I know and
your listeners know that Bitcoin there
really is regulatory clarity it's not a
security it's totally legal it you know
fits under existing commodity
infrastructure ever commodities like
CFTC regulatory infrastructure and but
to a lot of people that they don't
really believe that whereas you have an
ETF it just done it just this is safe
it's clean it's fully endorsed by
every regulatory body in the US which
means every most countries around the
world will follow suit and then you get
a little bit of passive exposure and
like pensions and it becomes very hard
to ban because suddenly um this is a big
a big question that gets asked like why
are why are bitcoiners like you and I
who believe in decentralization believe
in some of the cyberpunk ethos why are
we championing in ETF and banks at
getting into space and fidelity in
custody and the answer for me is that
the game theory of Bitcoin long term
which Satoshi understood was you need to
gradually get more and more people to
have skin in the game and that's the
only way we win this war long term that
if this is 30 million people against all
the governments of the world we lose
period we lose so that the game here is
to almost trick the world into gradually
adopting it without them knowing how big
of a threat it is to the existing status
quo so this is super interesting because
I actually haven't said this publicly
yet but one of the things everyone seems
to be under estimating is this Ohio
accepting Bitcoin is crypto and it's not
because oh now that answers the question
of like it's accept it as you know to
pay taxes so it's a currency type thing
I think that's you know one data point
but a government official went in and
created a rule that legitimized a
digital decentralized currency and said
we as a state entity will accept it how
does the US government come behind and
span it they could they could say that
federally we can ban this yep I think it
becomes really really hard to do when
you have states that got ahead of you
Wyoming now Ohio accessor and they're
accepting it they're embracing it that
they're championing it it just becomes
hard for the federal government to come
in and be the bad guy now certainly
makes it harder especially yeah you
think it starts getting frames like a
states rights versus federal rights
although I do see that somewhat
ironically and the political parties
have flipped on this it's not the
Democrats who are for states rights so
like with cannabis right so you have the
FBI raiding legal California
dispensaries which is the most absurd
thing gradiant you you have a regulated
legal entity in California that you know
is paying taxes and then you have the
FBI raiding it and shutting it down to
claiming that it's illegal claiming it's
eally all right so just it's pizza
are so but the point is it can't happen
I wouldn't I think it's a really
meaningful that it is a meaningful data
point as part of this trend which is
just a little more bi and a little more
legitimate a little legitimization
psychologically which is huge finance is
all about trust trust the people talk
about the linee effect way too much of
crypto I think it's it's just why so as
a concept it's basically a hand wavy
soft science stylized description
it isn't predictive it's descriptive
there's no science to it it there is no
like I mean there's literally no science
to it it's a description of an empirical
observation with very very weak evidence
basically it's a fancy way of saying
things have been around a while are more
likely to be around a while and it's a
way of making that kind of truism seem
scientific and and but I think if you
actually dig into it like why is that
true at the margin so I think it is a
little bit true um and why is it true I
think it's largely psychology of trust
which is why do we so JPMorgan almost
every year gets fine for money
laundering for a city but group just uh
or Citibank just got fine for creating
like 30,000 fake customer accounts and
yet no one wonders if Citibank is gonna
be around to next year no one is worried
about Citibank ceasing to exist why
because because we just kind of know
that like we trust the things that been
around for a while we'll continue to be
and that gets into like the nature of
power so basically Citigroup has so many
lobbyists and there's so much skin in
the game in that regard and there's so
many voters who work at Citigroup or
Bank they're that politicians are very
unlikely to shut down regulators are
likely to be friendly is a too big to
fail there's all sorts of like sociology
and political science whatever that goes
into that but as humans we just know
that something's been around for thirty
years is probably not going away next
year and so establishing that trust with
Bitcoin and that's one of the coins
biggest advantages over its competitors
because you can't leapfrog that you
can't replicate time you can't write you
can't create a tenure track record in
six months you just can't so this gets
at this point where people was asked you
know is Bitcoin always gonna be the king
is that always gonna be the winner of
that and I tend to answer normally with
anytime you've got a currency that is
the defect or default it got ahead it
has the notoriety it has the hash rate
it has the adoption it's got kind of the
mental capture if you will right if
another currency was to leapfrog that
people would always look over their
shoulder
with the second currency saying is there
a third that's gonna leapfrog that right
it's really hard to store your wealth in
something that you've seen get replaced
and then not worry about it being
replaced again I don't know if that's
actually true or if it's a slick way to
explain some game theory that you know
there's hints of truth in it and but it
doesn't actually apply what's your take
on that again I think it's descriptive
not predictive and what I mean by that
it's a little bit like in 2007 when I
was talking with colleagues about hey uh
and I was actually a huge fan of Nora or
beanie at the time it wasn't that he
time the financial crisis he actually
called it like six years too early but
he actually laid out a really deep
understanding so I was talking to
colleagues and I said guys I'm reading
this no roubini guy I'm doing some
fact-checking it seems logical and I
think I'm like I've confirmed some of
the big data points he says we're gonna
have some prime brokers failing and they
would say if a prime broker fails it's
the end of the world therefore it can't
happen it's a it's like it's like a
weird circular reasoning it's like I'm
gonna be the equivalent of saying like
I'm on a plane if the plane crashed I'd
be dead therefore the plane won't crash
it doesn't actually make sense to say
that so the argument that Bitcoin can
never be replaced because that would be
the end of crypto doesn't mean Bitcoin
doesn't get replaced that isn't
predictive at all right would it what
you can maybe say is either it's Bitcoin
or it's nothing that that could follow
actually strongly disagree though so why
the same logic applies for almost any
strong Network effect based technology
that requires faith and buy-in with
money it's more but bitcoins not money
yeah it's it's speculative no one is
using it as money anyone who is half
their net worth in Bitcoin is not
thinking that they're storing half their
net worth in Bitcoin they're just huge
believers that they're going to get
ultra wealthy by doing that I think the
way that we've seen this play out this
is this is every tech boom in history is
you get a crisis of confidence the early
movers die and not always not not every
early mover but usually most of the
first movers die and then there is a
crisis of confidence and it takes people
a while and it takes a long time to
recover that confidence and rebuild it
but it happens so in the scenario where
let's say there was a critical bug found
in Bitcoin tomorrow that just in some
way just wiped out the network and could
not before it could not be fixed and
even the core Dabbs even the true
believers wash their hands they're like
you know what failed experiment a huge
fundamental flaw and Byzantine through
it's not Byzantine fault Allah or
whatever
um I think you'd have a massive crypto
depression where everything's down 99.9%
where the industry basically ceases to
exist you'd have it would probably go
back to what maybe it looked like in
2010 or 2011 so you'd have some hardcore
cypherpunks you'd have maybe you know a
couple hundred thousand people who are
passionate believers and then they would
gradually slowly resuscitate the
industry over a decade and you know it's
not that different from the 2000 tech
crisis except it would probably last
longer probably be a deeper shaking of
confidence you might take 20 years to
restore confidence in at the retail
level I actually don't think would take
20 years though because people people
have firm memories I mean and people
said the same thing it's a much weaker
effect with something like Friendster to
MySpace to Facebook but it's the same
idea which is people have to invest time
and onboard to something and then when
it fails they're disillusioned and it's
truthy as investors and as users but
people get over it because if the value
is clear and you have a small number of
people who start growing those grass
roots and believe in it then you you
create new confidence from scratch
almost what do you think the probability
of Bitcoin failing is so you can't say
it goes to zero because as long as
somebody's running it it's running right
but but failing in the sense of it's no
longer the dominant crypto it's lost
you know majority of its value etc so
there's no real way to quantify those
three it's unknown unknown like that I
don't think I think you can apply some
really high level heuristics very hand
wavy right so very honest about it so
that's a fair cure the number I throw
out and this is this maybe users
directional is I say 50/50 that bitcoin
is basically exists in 20 years and I
exist again as you said like it'll
probably exist in some form but I mean
exist as as I don't know we could define
that as having at least 10 billion
dollars in total network value or
something so how do I come up with that
so first mover's very rarely win with
new technology especially if it's tech
because tech becomes obsolete tech
innovates or it dies now bitcoins not
only tech of course but that first key
element that what are the odds the first
Byzantine fault-tolerant consensus
mechanism ever implemented is the best
and what are the odds we're not gonna
find something ten times a hundred times
a thousand times better very unlikely in
my view just just knowing the history of
technology
what are the odds that the first
distributed ledger form architecture
used for a cryptocurrency is the best
where the odds blockchain is the best
type of distributed ledger for this so
blocks need arbitrary so it's a type of
dag a fun little data point by the way
in crypto we talk about DAGs a separate
directed acyclic graphs we talked about
like iota or were some of the other
there aren't that many but they're a few
I'm totally blanking on the name of one
of the other big ones but um technically
a blockchain is the type of dag it's
it's a narrow case of a dag a crypto
doesn't have to use a blockchain there
are lots of other distributed ledger
types that may be more efficient what
are the odds that Satoshi and basically
his first attempt kind of locked on the
best type now I know it wasn't his first
attempt he built on 50 years of previous
work but point is this is a new
technology what are the odds that we
it's like but the temp car off the
assembly line is the best one that can
ever be made so that's one side that's
why it dies now why does it live because
this isn't a technology that's one key
part but it's also it's money right and
so money the creation myth that is based
probably it impossible to reproduce the
Immaculate Conception story of Bitcoin
is so underrated I actually would argue
that is the biggest network effect and
all of crypto that is the biggest moat
sorry that's the biggest and that is the
biggest competitive advantage so open
source code is easily forked the network
effects are minimal so 18 if the coin
ATMs could add iota or ripple or
whatever they want pretty quickly you
could that NASA can launch if you're in
futures or anything else very quickly
the dev community people I think it's
very important short term it's trivial
long term so if we're gonna have a
hundred thousand crypto developers in 20
years we don't need a single aetherium
developer to be in that group and I'm
not trying to attack aetherium it's just
the developer community it's it's here's
that here's my fair analogy Facebook
didn't need a single Friendster user to
win love that yeah like if you're
talking about an addressable market
that's gonna involve a billion people
you don't need the current 30 million
people to be part of that at all
literally at all and the same is true
for the developer community so on that
side Bitcoin as the first mover as money
as capturing mind share is a global
brand as having this creation story
that's bits
really hard to reproduce if not
impossible is incredibly powerful and
then I think this is critical
Bitcoin probably just needs to be good
enough so when you think out incumbents
in any trust based model like Lloyd's of
London insurance they're not competing
at the margins so a slightly better
technology if I can buy coca-cola for
10% cheaper
I don't kill coca-cola mm-hmm if I can
be Lloyd's of London with slightly
better customer service at vocaloids of
London because it's really about trust
or brand you need something much better
to kill that so if I could produce
coca-cola for five cents a can I could
probably kill coca-cola or if I could be
Lloyd's of London with you know open
24/7 with branches everywhere maybe I
kill it so what does that look like for
Bitcoin how much better does something
have to be because of layer 2 and
interoperability the answer might be
near infinite so this is something I
don't have a clear view on but basically
so Bitcoin at now it's roughly 13
transactions per second transaction fees
will rise exponentially if Bitcoin
succeeds in a good way that just means
there's actual demand for space on the
blockchain I very much think we're gonna
have technologies that support with
equal security a thousand x the
transaction volume and one thousandth of
price but that might just be able to be
added as a layer two and so if the base
so the big here's way to be freaky view
I think so people understand this
because again layer 2 layers through
think people shake their head oh yeah I
know what that isn't have no clue so
maybe just go through the network being
layer 1 and what layer 2 layer 3 means
and maybe we can even compare it to like
money visa etc just spend like two
minutes on that real quick sure so first
that the the trickiest thing to
newcomers is often that Bitcoin you have
the Bitcoin protocol which is a network
in a in a communication language by
which computers will communicate with
each other and then you have Bitcoin the
currency which is a little knowing that
they're the same name in aetherium you
have if you're in the network ether at
the token and that's critical because
then you have a layer 2 which is a
separate protocol that can literally be
very different so lightning network is a
layer 2 protocol and Bitcoin
it is a separate protocol meaning like
if you literally look at the code it's
very different the way it functions is
very different the way communication
messages are transferred between
computers are very different it's layer
2 because of how it sits on top of
Bitcoin where you use bitcoins in
lightning Network
and your and your bitcoins used in
lightning Network are I'm not a good
definer of light network but Lightning
Network basically locks to the Bitcoin
blockchain
and snaps on top now Lightning Network
could snap on top to other networks you
can do Lightning Network on litecoin you
can do lightning network theoretically
on basically anything so lightning
network doesn't have to use bitcoins but
if it's if it's layer 2 on Bitcoin it
uses bitcoins and the nice thing is we
can add these layer twos that do
anything so you can do and and one way
to think about this a little bit and I'm
lumping a lot of different technologies
together because the functionality is
very similar in this context state
channels side chains these are all ways
of basically creating a separate
protocol or separate Network or separate
self-contained box to do that has the
features the trade-offs the security the
costs the transaction speed of whatever
technology allows and then you can link
that back to a base chain and
cryptographically secure way so there's
I don't I don't I don't need a terms
like atomic swaps there's a very
interesting cryptography that allows you
to prove and link and lock that that
relationship but basically I can create
the standalone network that has any any
trade-offs or functionality I want and
so Bitcoin as the money as the currency
may be able to win and survive even
though Bitcoin the protocol becomes
horribly obsolete well so I think the
comparison that I usually use in you
shoot holes in it is Bitcoin the network
is very similar to the physical paper
dollar right and it is something that
can be I'm sorry a bit like the original
Bitcoin right so not the network but
Bitcoin itself and a physical dollar you
can use it for some things you can move
it around pretty inefficient though if
you want to do global commerce things
like that when all of a sudden you start
to build the layer 2 layer 3
technologies on top of that visa for
example is a layer 3 type technology
that allows you to move the equivalent
of those physical paper dollars but you
actually don't have to have physical
paper dollars and you can do it in a
much more efficient lower-cost way if
you want to do global commerce the
things like lightning and other layer 2
layer 3 technologies will allow you to
transact bitcoins in a much more
efficient lower-cost way with
actually having to make bitcoins
themselves obsolete actually builds on
top of it and improves it without
changing that core component but I don't
think that we're there yet there's
things that are being built and they're
interesting it's unfair for us to have
to answer the question today well how
come bitcoins aren't used the same way
visa is used right it's it's an apples
to orange comparison that if you're not
super deep in the technology and don't
understand this stuff you actually don't
understand yet you're asking the wrong
question right kind of talking heads on
television etc sure sure yeah I mean I
think one of the things that is such a
constant thing trying like since getting
into crypto I've done a lot more reading
on specifically tech booms in the past
and history really repeats in this
regard
every single time everyone and and I'd
say I fall prey to this a little bit too
is we get very excited about
world-changing technology we're right
that it's going to change the world
we're right directionally it takes five
to ten times as long as everyone thinks
so this you know you look at the 2014
boom in Bickle or twenty sorry 2013 boom
in Bitcoin everyone was convinced that
we're gonna be buying coffee with it the
next day and like five years later we're
still not right and then you look at
aetherium and the massive bubble in q4
with all these taps coming out and it's
like oh we're gonna have I mean I'll
pick on a success case so augur great
team great vision they executed they
delivered a product that works and is
like a hundred daily active users an
augur may still make conquer the world
so they're they're improving the UI
they're improving if he really needs to
be on a more scalable platform to have
lower costs there's all sorts of thing
of incremental improvements that they
can and will make so I'm not saying that
it's a done deal and a failure at all
but here's an example where people who
invested in augur almost four years ago
so the augur white paper I think
preceded the etherium white paper or was
almost at the same time it took like
four years to launch a product that no
one wants to use is that a failure and I
would say no augers a success case it
just takes a really long time to contain
technology except load a company in a
product but I would send beyond that
because you actually are trying to
bootstrap entirely new network effects a
good analogy here might be Tesla where
not only do you need a new company and a
new type of car and to educate a
consumer you need
build a network of charging stations
across the entire country and to think
that you know to say like well electric
cars and replace gasoline yet therefore
they never will you know we have a
hundred years of gasoline-powered cars
or maybe not quite a hundred years but
you know network effects that take a
long time spread and so the best example
of this email was invented in 1972 in
1982 almost no one in the world used it
in 1988 some big companies used it in
1992 well under 10% of the world had
access to email it was about 10% of
Americans it was about 1% of the world
20 years after email was invented you
could have looked at and said it's been
20 years 1% of the world uses this thing
clearly it's never gonna get used it's a
failure it's a niche hobby and this
stuff just takes a long time and as
investors we make that mistake over and
over and over we get over optimistic we
invest in things that are too early
evaluations that imply they're gonna be
cashflow positive in a year or two when
it's actually a decade away a concern I
have as an investor is is that first
mover question which is is okay I look
at the landscape right now actually I'll
use I'll use as a very concrete example
security tokens so hugely popular right
now it's the sexy thing it's it's like
the thing that people have confidence in
in a bear market where no one's using
gaps when I look at that space which I
haven't I haven't spent a ton of time
diving really deeply my mate security
tokens absolutely are gonna be a thing
like there's no quite actually think
regulators are gonna require security
tokens because they're gonna require
that regulations are can be programmed
into securities I actually think they're
gonna require it but that might be 20
years away for the required so when I
look at the landscape and you look at
some of the players right now my concern
is what if none of them are the ones
that win what if in five years none of
them exist and its new entrants who
actually capture that market because I
think meaningful security issuance is
going to be a slow and steady gradual
kind of increase and I don't know that
any of the existing entities are the
winners so it's a little bit like if you
wanted to invest in Facebook in 1996
well it wouldn't be born for eight more
years and the startups you would have
invested in all failed all the social
media startups prior to prior to 2000
failed so you had the right thesis the
right idea the right long-term vision
you were so early the winner didn't
exist that's a serious concern for a
crypto investor the search engines same
thing total
right is what was a 22nd 23rd one I
think Google that if you had literally
invested in the first 15 yeah you you
just throw struck now it's tough so so
so how do you solve that as investor you
take the VC approach and kind of
scattershot you know so you you have a
portfolio of 25f you know plays and and
you're hoping one or two of them or big
winners you can try to be an active
trader who kind of responds in real time
so you're not gonna catch Google in its
seed stage maybe you wait till it's
Exchange listed but um so I'll tell you
a big thing I spend a lot of time trying
to think about if something kills
Bitcoin what will it look like
because here's one way to think about
investing in crypto I'm actually I'm not
recommending this as a strategy this
isn't quite what I do but I actually
think it's not like a terrible base
framework which is okay I'm gonna have
most of my crypto money in Bitcoin as as
part of the market leader with also
probably air quotes the safest not
saying it's safe but probably safer than
most and then I'm so confident the
crypto is gonna conquer the world I want
a non-trivial amount of my net worth in
it that's really a bet I want to make
but I know that Bitcoin isn't a hundred
percent to win so I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna invest in this is all hypothetical
by the way this is not how I invest but
you can say I'm not gonna invest in
tangential use cases like decentralized
file storage decentralized computing
dissenters whatever that those there's
gonna be value there but I'm just not
gonna pay attention and not spending all
my time diligences so I'm gonna be in
Bitcoin and I'm going to make tiny tiny
bets early in the things that I think
might credibly kill Bitcoin and so maybe
I'm 90% in Bitcoin 10% over time you
know 0.2% in each one these things that
could kill Bitcoin so the idea there is
you're probably gonna underperform
Bitcoin that 10% is probably an or 0 but
if Bitcoin goes up a hundred X I don't
care I'm very happy making 90 X on my
money instead of a hundred x the worst
scenario is you're right on the thesis
crypto conquers the world and you lose
your money because you weren't in the
thing that wins so you don't want to
stupidly diversify that's not a reason
just throw your money into things that
will go to zero because they're broken
but it does make it sensible to kind of
focus on that if you have a clear thesis
that there's going to be something like
a winner-take-all and you're very
confident crypt is gonna conquer the
world then think in terms of what does
the winner have to look like almost how
would an index type strategy fit into
that this is tough so I'm a big fan of
passive indexing which sounds we
as as an active manager who was
financially incentivized to say the
opposite but I mean I want financial
markets to serve to serve people like
the issue encrypt oh so my first job at
Susquehanna actually not quite my first
but a year in was to profit off of ETFs
that held commodities in a very
mechanical way so ok USO is a commodity
that as an ETF exchange-traded fund it
trades like an equity and it holds crude
oil and it holds crude oil futures and
investors and that passively just get to
hold USL and what the the ETF does is
every month it rolls from holding the
first month futures to the second month
futures and so my job was to basically
buy the second month futures before the
ETF and then sell right after that was
like one of 50 trading strategies but
that was one thing it was wildly
profitable in 2007 2006 through 2008
until basically every other trader in
the world figure it out so if you
invested in us oh you underperformed
crude oil because of people like me
because of traders who took advantage of
this bad index construction so the issue
here is that every index is gamma Bowl
to greater or lesser degree a really
well-constructed index will have very
minimal slippage traders won't be able
to make much money off it a poorly
constructed index is a playground for
traders who will just like I am I got to
tell you as an active manager
I can't wait for there to be huge money
flowing into indexes because I'm gonna
wreck them yeah but explain that more
yeah and let me say by the way I don't I
don't want retail to get wrecked so I'm
actually going to actively advise every
index on what it is they're doing wrong
like I'm gonna try to actually advise
and warn them not to do things that
would allow me and other traders to take
advantage it's like re re Paul the white
hat trader I'm not gonna say I'm not
gonna say that I'm not gonna pretend
that it's uh that I'm doing good it's
it's just the point is the goal is I
would like no one to get rapped like
genuinely but if there's an index that's
gonna get wrecked that's kind of my
fiduciary obligation and job to find
trading opportunities so I'm sorry what
was the question of how how you yeah oh
so let me give an example so let's say
you do a top five index and you have a
very illiquid coin that on very little
volume it's currently let's say the 30th
coin I can make it the fifth biggest
coin let's say you leave an example you
say you're gonna make an index of top
five coins and you're gonna calculate
that based on coin market Capcom at
midnight at the end of the month so
let's say there's someone in Estonia
who's a market manipulator and what they
do is they take the thirtieth biggest
coin they take bit connect and in that
one-minute period they manipulate the
price up the coin market cap reports it
as a fifth largest coin you as the index
now have to buy that coin and you've to
buy it at this massively inflated market
cap the next day the thing Falls 80% the
end of that month you then sell it rinse
and repeat
every month you would put massive money
into pic connect and at the end of every
month you would sell after you've lost
ninety percent very easy to see that
happening now that's that's kind of a
stylized case that's really extreme that
exact thing is almost guaranteed how
does an index prevent that so there's no
perfect solution a few things one people
this sounds weird but actually having
human discretion I think is as part of
the solution any set of any set of
really clearly defined rules is capable
so with this is true with the S&P 500
with the CMA futures there's always a
committee that has the ability to
overrule so in the event of really clear
market manipulation or let's say it's
defined the corn market Capcom and coin
market cap is hacked you want there to
be a human who can say you know what
maybe a dental cone is not the biggest
coin in the world so having a some
element of human discretion to overrule
and there's clear market manipulation or
just clear failures and whatever the
system is having very very gradual
rebalancing so if you have a one minute
window to define when you rebalance the
index that's very gheymeh below
if instead you make it a if you seven do
you make it based on the price that is a
time weighted average over five days far
harder to manipulate much more expensive
to manipulate those are the biggest and
then there's execution so if you're
rebalancing on a day that's easy to gain
if you rebounds averaged over time
averaged over a week so the ultimate
here would be continuous rebalancing so
if you say we're going to continuously
redefine what's in our index and
continuously trade to rebalance that's
very hard to game it's also harder to
execute it's more expensive you're gonna
shower our management fees but that's
probably the thing is our trader would
look at me like I don't know what to do
with this mm-hmm
how does crypto perform during a global
recession so we've seen crypto do
incredibly well from a return standpoint
even with the big draw downs through
what's been the longest bull run in
equity market you know ever how do you
think it performs or how do you or how
would you from a mental framework
evaluate how it will perform during it
some sort of economic retraction or
recession um so I I think it entirely
depends on the nature of the drawdown
and recession now the vast majority of
equity sell offs and recessions are
deflationary in nature and that that
probably is a safe assumption that that
will generally be true going for it in
in a deflationary recession crypto sells
off there's no reason why wouldn't it's
a risk asset in deflation you actually
that means the dollar is gaining value
now I think that inflationary recessions
are far more likely over the next 20
years and they've ever been in the past
we have unprecedented debt we have
unprecedent money printing we've had
very very I would argue artificially low
inflation over the last decade in the
face of massive money printing for a lot
of reasons including tech advancement
and outsourcing of labor to develop
markets where there's a very very cheap
labor who basically export deflation so
all these reasons I think a inflationary
equity sell-off is more likely than
usual maybe it's 50 50 or 70 percent in
that scenario crypto potentially does
very well so Ray Dalio is the founder of
bridgewater one of the biggest hedge
funds in the world he's viewed as one of
the best investors of all time he's up
there with Warren Buffett he's been
making the rounds recently saying that
he thinks the US dollar will lose global
reserve status or at least had that
publicly threatened in about two years
anything that is so wild for a majority
of Americans to think about yeah it's
weird and I'm not saying he's wrong
right I'm not saying he's right or wrong
I'm just saying that idea that the US
dollars at global reserve currency could
be threatened in 24 months
he's incomprehensible to majority of
Americans totally well I think most
Americans frankly don't even know what
that means I don't mean as an insult
absolutely completely agree I think they
don't like like what does that mean and
you know very raw like like average
person sense it means that like most
people if they're tourists and they
travel anywhere they're use dollars are
good we've actually seen rebut like that
story among macroeconomic
Micmac global macro hedge fund managers
among macro economists is not at all
surprising I think here's the psychology
right now people have been saying this
for 10 years to the point that it ceases
to feel real but we've had data points
for ten years it's just these things
often take a really long time and so
people stop saying it so if you were an
economist who was predicting this ten
years ago and he'd years ago in six
years ago eventually you give up because
you've just been wrong I actually wrote
an essay about this I think in 2009
about how I thought it would happen in
about four years and at some point you
just stopped writing about it cuz like
you know it you don't be the guy who
cried wolf every year right so Dalio
this is the first time he's ever said it
it in kind of a concrete way he seems
very thoughtful about the timeline and
the triggers we see tons of data points
on this so China is very actively trying
to make this happen so they have
bilateral trade deals with Russia with
Japan so it's not even just it's not
like just the evil axis countries that
we think of Japan is pushing hard which
is frankly a little bit weird to me and
I'm not really like I used to be much
more up-to-date on global macro but it's
weird cuz they own a massive amount of
US debt so I'm not sure what their
incentives are but they've entered
bilateral trade deals that are basically
international trade not to nominee
newest dollars crude oil being
denominated in gold there's a lot of
these data points around the world that
people making this happen and then you
have the geopolitics of Trump
administration using here's a good line
the the Treasury Department no sorry the
Swift system is the military wing of the
US Treasury Department so if we don't
like a country we cut them out of the
global banking system yet we've done
that with Iran we did that with North
Korea we I think we do it with Venezuela
and it and it is wrapped in the the bow
of sanctions right it's you ever seen a
Kim er if it's Kevin Hart or Chris Rock
but they they talk about insurgents
they're right when we go to war right oh
yeah but like no one's like oh we're
gonna go kill humans right there was AI
word Co insurgents everyone it's like I
don't know just fine kill mall okay like
bragging like it's the way the
vernacular we use actually nobody
humanizes it say there was sanctions
right like oh thanks you're gonna apply
sanctions no I don't know what that is
sure not just if I would put sanctions
on them right right if we phrased it as
we are going to turn off their money
very different far scarier and yeah and
and there's a I mean it's very real so
that like the Swift system it's
so first if anyone listening to this if
you try to google search the Swift
system and actually understand how it
works with public information it's
remarkably difficult it's it's actually
a very secretive air quotes kind of
process and I say secretive like that's
kind of literally true there's a
remarkably little that's public about it
how it actually works
I love diving into trying to figure out
actual axis of power so for example the
Internet I think is kind of owned and
controlled by the US and there's some
data points so I can which is the
illiterate literally they actually
control domain name registration it's a
company based in California they fall
under California laws but they actually
used to be entirely US owned and then
they were like equity ownership was
transferred to an international
consortium that's a non-profit and so
like I did a bait like like should we
think of it as US owned because it you
know it's like the United Nations is on
US soil but you know it's probably not
us controlled Swift I'm actually not
sure who really controls it so the US
certainly has massive power there and
probably the US has access to every
single transaction that flows through
the network so there's been a few
lawsuits including between countries
involving the US and the EU over Swift
spine so the US has actually got in
trouble for getting caught for spying on
European countries transferring money
between each other
interesting um but exactly how much
control the US has over Swift I don't
know is it like soft power we just
convince our European allies but the
point is if you're almost anyone it's a
little bit concerning and if that weapon
starts getting wielded more frequently
if it becomes almost a common thing but
oh the u.s. is going to disconnect a
country from global money massive
incentive massive reason for those
countries to start thinking about
cryptocurrency for sure before we wrap
up a quick-fire of questions and then
we'll end it I always let everyone ask
me one question what is the most
important company in crypto other than
block tower right now I I would call us
one of the least important if the devs
really do the important work oh what's
the most I'll give a shout-out to
lightning labs which is one of the you
know I don't I don't wanna insult any of
the other lightning companies cuz
there's plenty people doing great work
but uh Elizabeth Stark runs the company
they're building the Lightning that work
on top of Bitcoin which is so critical
for Bitcoin to achieve consumer adoption
and what's great about lightning is
they've partnered with square who are
really consumer people so the Lightning
labs team has some world-class engineers
but I don't know if they have
world-class UI developers maybe they do
I'm not trying to salt them but um but
then you bring on square and it's like
about these guys really know how to make
a consumer product so Super Value I
think when we talk about what crypto we
might achieve mass consumer adoption
next year - it's not the sci-fi use
cases it's not dowels that might be
happen in ten years it's the simple kick
vision that Satoshi had it's just can we
actually use this thing for remittance
and p2p cash and lightning such a
critical part of that awesome what's the
most controversial thought that you have
about crypto you know it's such a
fractured community it really depends on
who I'm talking to
saying that bitcoin is 50/50 to die is
certainly very contentious to some
people and it's funny when talking to
non crypto people they're like you're
that bullish you really think the first
stone first technology is 50% to live
for 20 years
oh here's one here's one um proof of
work as a consensus mechanism maybe
basically proven to not work - I may be
debunked so it has all sorts of game
theory vulnerabilities many of which
Satoshi explored you have things like
eclipse attacks and you know we're
seeing SV and ABC play out in in real
time now and what's scary about that
battle is the low dollar cost so the
cost of doing a constant threat of a
reorganization attack where you
basically erase an indefinite amount of
transactions and replace the Bitcoin
ledger with empty blocks or blocks of
your choice it's actually not expensive
it's it's almost shockingly cheap and
that's for sv and ABC for Bitcoin it's
something like roughly 10x the price to
do the same attack so we're not at state
level prices yet we're at we're at not
even a billionaire prices yet we're at
like okay you got five hundred million
dollars and you want to erase a day of
Bitcoin transactions you can do that mmm
how many times does that have to happen
before people say you know proof-of-work
the idea that the ledger is immutable
are we really gonna believe that after
the ledger is mutated five times
probably not we probably can't say that
anymore right so there's some chance
that this - this is not a black and
white thing it's not an engineering
question these are well known game
theory attacks the question is really
how does that plug into human psychology
to business to economics to vested
interest here's a very
pacific example or critical point of
this before shorting was possible in
size a rational economic actor would
never do a reorganization attack on a
blockchain so 51 percent attacks the
defense against it could be mining
diversification or it could just be
rational economic actors if bit main had
a hundred percent of bitcoin hash power
their incentive is to be a good actor
because they've this massive investment
in fixed dates it cost so the fact that
they have a hundred percent shouldn't
scare you as long as they're a rational
economic actor who can't short the
minute you have the ability to shorten
great great size a rational economic
actor who owns a hundred sent of the
coin hash power may destroy a bitcoin
and that could mean also a cartel so if
you have five entities that each control
fifteen percent they are actually
potentially incentivized to do these
game theory tax approval yep not a
prediction just saying it's it's a
that's certainly contentious view to say
guys this isn't like you know let me
rephrase this way it's not that we're
i'm not claiming that we're not sure
proof of work is sound i'm making a
stronger claim we know for certain that
under certain conditions that don't seem
that extreme proof of work is not sound
as it stands today so the question is
just how how realistic are those edge
cases got it i think that is a fairly
controversial it's pretty good what's
your favorite book or the most important
book you think people should read oh I'd
recommend the sovereign individual I
love that it starts with a horrible
prediction that about the y2k bug which
is sets the stage because they're books
like that that are incredibly convincing
you read them and I'm like wow they just
told me what the next thirty years are
gonna look like and of course no one is
crystal ball so it starts with a
horrible prediction which is just
wonderful and then it's incredibly
thought-provoking about the
interrelationship between politics
military power and economics long term
and it talks about how the average size
of nation-states is likely to fall that
instead of being towards the current
leap I was a Poli Sci major so I love
this stuff we have been moving towards a
world where the thought was we're moving
towards like one global democracy like
more towards you know global power and
more debt and more democracy and this
makes the opposite argument that and and
which is my intuition that giant
democracies just don't work and don't
make sense their journey managed already
or you have been already representation
and then they're just gridlock instead
the ideas that people vote with their
feet you'll have a lot of little nation
states and
instead of changing your country maybe
they're all dictatorships but you get to
choose which one you want to live in and
you get to choose your rules in your
community and it's democracy via that
means so really really thought-provoking
let's admit that there are aliens this
is my one non crypto question every time
they're depicted they're always depicted
as human comparables in sci-fi etc what
are the odds that there are alien
animals or alien pets alongside those
human comparable aliens where's there
just one single species of aliens oh man
I guess this I would say pretty high but
I'm probably just projecting I think
whenever we try to imagine any alien
life we have to assume that their
consciousness is in some way comparable
to ours and humans where we are social
animals that demand companionship so my
assumption is that other intelligent
life would and I know that's an
assumption but and then the from
companionship I think you get something
like pets
I think it's fair I'm always faster the
reason why I asked this question I never
said it before but the reason why I
asked this question is not because I
actually care what the answer is I'm
fascinated by the way people will back
into their answer right what's the logic
behind it and I think that's a very
rational way to think about why there
would be bets all right one question do
you have for me
[Music]
no question III was just thinking
through a few I'll pick the one suit so
you're known for being a cheerleader of
the securitisation movement and and
processing and you know seeing that
vision what do you think let's say let's
say that you I'm fortunate enough to be
invited back on your podcast in two
years what does the securitized token
landscape look like at that point if you
ask me this 12 months ago I'd been like
oh man there's gonna be tons of volume
you know liquidity there's gonna be all
these assets etc like my one mistake or
one of many mistakes in thinking through
this stuff is the timeframe so you know
Bill Gates quote of we overestimate one
year and underestimate in 10 years I
think is like perfect for what people
in 2017 we're looking at this tokenized
securities I tend to agree with you that
regulars at some point are going to
mandate it so I wrote it I think it was
either earlier this year in 18 or end of
17 that you know as he's gonna mandate
this thing I was like you're crazy why
would they ever do that but whatever and
I thought at the time was you know XML I
think they mandated in like oh six oh
seven the use of Edgar like 90 to 93 you
know sometime in there like they're
actually pretty far ahead of a lot of
this technology and getting people to
use this stuff and so to your point like
the ability to program the law into code
which then takes the regulator's from
being reactive right so who are you guys
what did you do that's illegal let's
build a case spent all these time money
and resources and then go enforce on you
and and you know convict you is really
expensive time-consuming cetera
if they can just prevent all of that and
be proactive by having the code prevent
us from making that you know illegal or
non-compliant trade that's really
interesting to them right now they got a
trust a code there's a whole bunch of
things that are the inputs or
something's going into that so I tend to
think that will be a big driver of this
but before you get there I think you
guys see some data points some success
stories around you know the market
actually wants this right so you got to
see some issuers do it you got to see
some investors that are on the other end
of that trade we're starting to see it
but I've changed my mind a little bit
from I just think was all gonna be
equity based I'm becoming much much more
bullish on the bond market on blocks
these blockchain bonds or smart bonds
and it's this kind of intersection of
the current bond market is horribly
inefficient right in terms of it's super
expensive like I think it over I think
the set is over 80% of US bonds are
traded over the phone or via chat
service like it's 2018 right right that
that's pretty egregious it's a huge
market so you US bonds I think it's like
41 trillion international we add in you
know get to the global number it's like
over 120 trillion or something and then
the third thing is it's very very easy
to take the issuance of a bond and put
it onto a blockchain and make it a
digitally native asset so with equities
there's all sorts of HK
in kind of complexities that bonds don't
have that will actually in my opinion
make it easier to tokenize the bonds and
ensure cheaper faster more secure kind
of less manipulation etc then let's say
the equity markets and then the last
piece that kind of tie some of those all
together is just the current equity
market like public equity market
actually works pretty well right if you
and I want to go buy equities like we
can do that we know how to do that maybe
we don't like the fact that it's got two
day settlement time or whatever but it
serves our purpose and yes there are
people in international jurisdictions
that maybe have a hard time buying
public equities etc but for the most
part it serves its purpose for majority
of the people who want to participate in
that market I can't say the same thing
about bonds right because there's just
higher barriers to entry there's much
more kind of the less education there's
just a bunch of issues there and so it
feels to me the more that I kind of dig
into this stuff that bond market is
going to become tokenized digitized
whatever you want to call it faster and
it actually is where the institutional
capital is likely to flow first if you
were to tokenize both assets actually
think that most institutional capital
would go more towards that fixed income
type stuff that's all I got for you it's
a great answer thanks for joining the
podcast I I usually get questions like
how do I go viral on Twitter it's but no
I think well I learned something from
that so I'm glad I asked a more you know
I don't know meaningful question
absolutely alright man thank you so much
for doing this we'll have to do this
periodic because I think you've got a
unique view in the world so thanks I
thanks for inviting me